[Music]
hello everyone
and welcome back to the road to 2000 as
always my name is caleb denby
and tonight i want to take you through
some uh some of the greatest chess
swindles
in all of chess history now many of you
are probably fans of popular chess
streamers and youtubers
such as eric rosen you know uh
honestly eric rosen is probably all-time
best swindler of the popular youtube and
twitch
crowd these days um and he was my
inspiration for picking our first game
of the show here
so we're going to take a look at this
game between michael chigorin
and carl schlechter and maybe we'll see
that eric rosen's
uh ideas are not so fresh after all it's
all
in chess history gotta study up even for
your spindles all right we have e4
by mikhail chigorin we have carl
schlechter with the black pieces
coming out with e5 now trigoran's not
messing around
so we're going to get a king's gambit
here as you do back in the day
black ops for bishop c5 which is like
a legal chess move it develops a piece
but not the most common against the
king's gambit
these days of course there's a couple
lines of thought you can of course
accept the king's gambit you can
defend your pawn in the center is
another way to play
much more direct to sort of diffuse the
king's gambit at the beginner level
i like to recommend this move d5 it
offers some equality for black
probably not any more than that but it's
a lot easier to just equalize and get a
chess game with d5 here
and so bishop c5 is kind of a strange
move um
it's not immediately challenging the
center it's not supporting
the pawn on e5 like knight c6 or d6
would
and it's not of course taking the free
material instead though it is
challenging white's claim to the d4
square and we'll see how well that works
out for uh
for black here we get knight f3 by white
of course
trying to reassert the pressure over
this square and renew
the threats to the e5 pawn now of course
e takes f4
could still be played but then you're
sort of dealing with white taking over
the entire center
and that could be a bit of an issue here
and i don't know where the those arrows
are coming from okay
regardless so bishop c5 not the most
common knight f3 controlling the center
e takes f4
not going to be as good because you put
this bishop on this stupid square
that's why we get d6 by schlecter and
black is sort of committed to
controlling this square at the moment
that's why the main move here is
actually to continue with c3
for white and white is just planning to
continue this role down the center of
the board
and perhaps try and prove that black was
mistaken in the placement of this bishop
instead though this game takes a much
calmer approach with bishop c4
and going for activity we get knight f6
by schlecter d3
knight c6 knight c3 and we get normal
development
after a6 and now white makes a very
interesting
decision so if there's any king's gambit
aficionados in the chat room here
i'm curious what your thinking would be
in this position
so white to move here and sees an
interesting opening
advantage
and hello tristan in the chat who is
mentioning
our saturday classes in parks throughout
the city of st louis
that's right look up chess pocket parks
i was
out and about on the town last saturday
myself played in the one
played in a tournament actually in one
of these chess pocket parks
it's a lot of fun some really cool
people are coming out enjoying
chess in the city of st louis as the
weather gets a bit nicer
bishop takes f7 check so this is a class
on swindles
but uh in this case trigorin is not
going to be the swindler with bishop
takes f7 it's a bit too much
right uh whenever you play a move like
bishop takes f7 there always has to be
some sort of immediate follow-up
where pieces like the queen are
immediately sort of coming into the game
and in this case
black is sort of controlling every
advancing square aside from
g5 and so you can play knight g5 but
after that
there's really no way to continue the
attack you can't bring anything else in
to continue attacking so bishop f7 not
going to be it here
instead the move that white chooses is
the interesting idea of
f5 so i think a lot of kings game of
players
would be a little bit reluctant to give
up on this idea of playing
f takes e5 and opening up the f-file
with an attack on f7
early on in the game but in this case
white is simply just seizing
a ton of space on the king's side and of
course
in the not so distant future if
something like g4
g5 is going to get uh going to appear on
the board
black could have some very serious
issues so f5
preventing by the way bishop e6 makes
this bishop even stronger
and that's why we see black immediately
play knight a5
f5 removes the option of bishop e6
trading the bishops
so black wants to remove this bishop
with knight a5
as quickly as possible if black were to
play something like
h6 a very very good move here for white
would be simply a3
with the point being now we can tuck
this bishop away a pretty common idea
also b4 ideas after bishop a2
worth pointing out so knight a5
immediately by schlecter we get
bishop g5 by whites giving up
the powerful light squared bishop
because it could not be saved
and going for this interesting pawn
structure that allows white to really
control the d5 square
and now we do see black make a pretty
fatal mistake
with the move of b5 of course
in this case moves like knight d5 are
simply going to be too strong
and black should be looking for a way to
kind of neutralize this threat as
quickly as possible and that's why the
best move here is actually bishop b4
you just take off this knight and now
this pressure against your knight
is not so severe you're not worried
about knight d5
and even if you were to play a move like
c6 instead
you now would potentially be worried
about other ways to route this knight
into the game
and you're creating weaknesses with this
move as well in the form of the d6 pawn
so b5 missing an opportunity to play
bishop b4
but the game continues now with queen e2
and we do see this c6 move by black and
after this concession of c6 white is
simply going to be better
we see queen side castles this pawn on
d6 is going to forever be weak
there's threats to the e5 pawn as well
and we're going to see
trigoran quite frankly outplay schlecter
for the rest of this game
queen c7 steps out of the pin we get
knight d2
uh bishop b7 knight b3 hitting this
bishop on c5
the bishop retreats in this instance and
now simply h4
and the power of this f5 pawn is
beginning to be felt
right it starts with h4 g4 g5
is not really a long shot at this point
either
by the way white can capture on f6 uh
whenever
he wants uh in order to fracture black's
pawns
and way too many weaknesses way too
passive of pieces
white has the safer king what's not to
like
black does castle queen sight in this
instance castling king's side would be a
bit too much with these pawns rolling
down the board
and we see trigoran actually lift this
rook in order to activate it on the
third rank
bc4 queen c4 d5 queen back to e2
and d4 so this is the counter play in
the position for black
sort of storming down the center of the
board but again
these pieces despite having now a little
bit of extra space
remain pretty passive in the position
and white should be significantly better
we get knight a4 just threatening some
of these dark squares
uh the dark square bishop as well we do
see c5 with pressure here
but again white was just waiting for the
opportune time to snap on f6
we get gf6 rookie one king b8
and now boring chess stuff trigoran's
the best rook on the open
file rick hg8 how dare you awful mistake
why would you put a rook on the open
file
um of course here facing the threats of
the rook
invading and threats to the c5 pawn
things are just happening on both sides
of the board and black could not keep it
together any longer
so rook hg8 of course the problem is
that this rook
is a little bit overworked and after
rook g8
or g8 we get knight b6 queen b6
knight c5 queen a5 and white
is simply up upon in this position along
with a pretty stunning attack on the
black king
so we get rook d1 by whites just
stepping out of the threat
rook takes g2 is going to be some
counter play for black
but with this super active knight
against the very passive bishop
and the lack of shelter around the black
king black is in for a very tough time
here so we do see
a4 by whites black tries to hide behind
the only shelter left for this king but
it's going to be pretty difficult still
to keep it safe we do see the move uh
sorry c3 here followed by queen b6 for
black of course if you start playing
moves like b take c
um at first glance it looks like you are
getting after
the white king here but in reality you
are leaving yourself open a little bit
to threats of rick d7 and there's
actually a winning tactic here right
away
with the move b4 keeping everything
locked down and then rook d7
is the end of the game so d takes c
unplayable that's the idea with c3 here
we get queen b6 by white
and then again this powerful b4 move
actually just shuts down the attack
there's just no
inroads for this queen to get a to get
after this white king and in the
meantime
the knight is very well placed on c5 so
we do see queen c7
and after cd4 bishop takes e4 uh carl
schlechter
is out here trying to stay in the game
of course this bishop was defending an
important pawn so we get this check
king b8 we get queen b5 check king a7
rook d2 and now at this point
uh schlechter i think understands that
he's probably going to be getting
checkmated here so he just trades off
the rooks
gives up on any rook c2 ideas any kind
of attack against the white king
and he says all rights let's try and
draw
some kind of end game here he plays d or
e takes d4
sacrificing a bishop and now at this
point in the game
white is completely winning like of
course how is white not completely
winning which is why we're going to flip
the board
and start our swindling class okay
enough for that boring chess stuff
where richard goran is just outplaying
his opponent with his extra space
with the multiple targets it's time to
start swindling
so e takes d4 sacrificing a bishop
all according to the plan because of
course now we do have queen f4
check and queen e3 check to pick the
bishop back
up and queen takes e4 okay
so that being said we got our piece back
we got ourselves a past
pawn you know we're in there with a hope
we're in there with a dream
unfortunately for us the dream is not
going to be very long-lived
queen d7 check king to b8
and now who sees what white should play
here
white to move what should we do
oh and everybody thinks i've been
hanging pieces all the time but
fortunately this isn't my chess game so
i don't think the pieces were actually
hanging
i can back up though see what's going on
okay nobody's falling for the trick
why is no one falling for the trick it's
a free pawn you gotta take the free pawn
you're supposed to say look the the pawn
on d4 is hanging
dang um so of course what's the problem
with taking the free pawn here
well this is sort of falling for a
pretty nice swindle
by schlecter all of a sudden you're
going to be getting
checked all over the board and pieces
are going to be flying
you might still be winning with white
but are are you really going to find
all the shelter sheltering moves that
you need you're going to be able to deal
with this pawn on f5 have you calculated
the king and pawn in game after queen b5
these are all very important questions
and the answer is no you're playing with
the white pieces you're like
this [ __ ] just played the worst chess
game of all time i'm not taking on d4
so nice little idea by schlechter here
to try and
you know almost bluff his way into
keeping white from taking on d4
uh and so white instead just plays the
move king c5 which is of course
entirely winning right these two past
pawns are way too strong compared to the
one
for for black we do see d3 by schlecter
i mean what else are you going to do
here with black you got to push your one
your one asset here down the board
b5 by white is pretty simple
and now uh the time has come to try and
not get checkmated so we see
schlecter play the move queen b7 uh
dodging checkmates now of course queen
takes is unfortunate for white when the
pawn will queen
so instead white just takes the free
pawn
we do see one check and now a very
important move by black
who sees by far the best practical
option here for black
there's only one move
there's only one move here to give
yourself chances
what do we think chad what do we think
when alberto did say take the pawn i
appreciate it so yeah kasparov
has the right answer as he always does
from 1891 which is of course you play
the move h5
any professional swindler will tell you
that having legal moves with your pawn
is a big no-no in these end games okay
you have to make sure
you have no legal pawn moves in order
for the swindles
to uh to work and maybe now the eric
rosen fans are beginning to uh to
understand where the influence is coming
from maybe not though
we'll see how it goes we'll see how it
goes so queen
to d4 is uh
white's attempt here just slowly but
surely
improving the queen getting ready to
push the pawns up the board
getting ready to play for checkmate we
do see
queen e7 check attacking the white king
king a5 and now black to move and
swindle
black to move and swindle i'm not saying
that black
is surviving this position just yet but
black is potentially coming up with
a really good swindle here so what do we
think chat
queen of four queen f4 what are you what
are you guys talking about with queen f4
okay you want to play queen f4 check
here
i see yeah i mean it's it's legal
right it's legal what are you gonna do
after uh
after king a5 though take this
i don't think you're going to take this
you get checkmated
so h5 of course the only move and now
we're looking at black to move and
swindle
okay you can't just give me the first
move of this one you have to give me the
full swindle
okay what are we hoping for with our
next move
what are we hoping to achieve
what are we hoping to achieve with our
swindle here
oh and aaron was so close in the chat
room but he stumbled at the last hurdle
stumbled at the last hurdle okay arthur
says we're playing for stalemate and
this is this is what eric rosen
will tell you so find the eric rosen
trick
it's like his only trick he normally
does it with a rook here but
now with the queen it's the same trick
so we're not
you know we're never getting it
perpetually here white has way too much
shelter
way too much shelter in front of this
king okay this king is like uncheckable
after queenie won king a6 it just cannot
be checked ever again
so we need something better need
something better here
arthur says queen c7 but what's the idea
arthur what's the idea
i'm not going to give this one away i'm
not going to give this one away
and there it is arthur has found the
game continuation
queen c7 check what
what a losing move what what kind of a
loser plays queen c7 check
of course i can block your check with
another check
forcing the trade of queens when of
course
you know white is completely winning in
the king and pawn end game
but what chagoran did not see is that
incredibly
king to a8 is drawing
the game this is a draw
and you may not believe me but it's true
black
is forcing stalemate here or a
repetition
so if queen takes c7 as in the game
well not in the game i think they agreed
to a draw but queen takes c7
is just stalemate this is the importance
of playing h5 everybody
and of course you might be thinking with
white well hold on
hold on a second i don't have to be an
idiot here um i can't legally move my
queen
except to take that's true but what if
ion pin
but unfortunately queen c8 check
and we're repeating and we are repeating
with queen c7 i think you also have
queen c3 but
that's less fun so queen c7 and
incredibly
white has no other waiting moves there's
no legal way to just like pass the turn
black to black
and it is zugzwang stalemate
very incredible stuff by schlecter
that's a nice swindle
and of course this is the the eric rosen
classic that's what i kept
referencing moving the king into the
corner after a queen is attacking a
piece
on c7 i don't know how many times i've
seen eric do this
to uh to people this one's a good one
this one's a good one
so of course white doesn't have to fall
for the trick which means you know it's
a swindle
if this just like was forcing the draw
then it wouldn't really even be a
swindle it's just like a tactic
but of course white can just play
something like b6 here
and it's still completely busted black
is just
getting checkmated sort of directly so
that's the first swindle
i have for you guys wanted to show you
that this eric rosen idea
maybe he didn't come up with it after
all maybe he is borrowing
from the great carl schlechter every
time
he draws these games uh usually in his
case i think it's
with a queen versus a rook he'll put his
rook on b6
or uh g3 and f2 in this case put the
king on h1
let the queen capture and then uh the
the game is agreed to be a draw
uh okay let us move on now uh so that
one i picked because it has a lot of
relevance
in modern day uh with eric rosen of
course
popularizing this kind of uh
this kind of stalemate but now i want to
move on to
what is known as the you know either
immortal stalemate game i might
i might no that's a different one but i
did i did a series on that
um this one is the stalemate of the
century of course maybe i need to do
another
video on game of the century spin-offs
this one
the stalemate of the century quote
unquote between
uh alexander beliavsky and the one
the only larry mark christensen
and we might actually see another game
from christensen later today
turns out this guy very good at
swindling but let's jump
let's uh jump into it we have beliavsky
with white pieces here we get d4
knight f6 c4 e6
g3 we see a check by black
bishop d2 queen e7
and this is some line in the catalan
that is not super popular today
um very funnily uh these days i think
people go bishop b4 check
and then they put the bishop back on e7
and black you know
is trying to claim some very fancy idea
about the bishop on d2 being misplaced
uh and it's interfering with all of
white's pieces and you would rather put
this bishop here but now you can't
because that's illegal
but none of that stuff for christensen
just queen e7 with a little bit more of
a reasonable idea
bishop g2 by white we get takes on d2
takes on d2
and d6 and we see christensen going for
this kind of dark squared setup
that uh players with the black pieces
tend to go for in openings like the
nimzo
where we do see an early bishop b4 and
the dark squared bishop getting traded
off
knight c3 by white castles by black
knight f3
and e5 is the natural continuation
kingside castles
is followed by rook e8 just bringing the
pieces into the center
and setting up this big uh not blockade
this big structure
with all of these pawns on the dark
squares preparing for
the rest of the game we get e4 by white
stopping the e
pawn in its tracks i think of course uh
if white were to play a slower move here
something like e4
e3 is potentially a tangible threat that
black could consider doesn't necessarily
have to go for it though
so instead we see e4 just to put a stop
to all of that
now bishop g4 develops this bishop out
not really a lot of other great squares
for this bishop
now we do see d5 closing the center
takes an f3 takes on f3
knight bd7 and now we see white
uh of course start to outplay black as
tends to happen in these uh kinds of
structures i'm very biased when it comes
to these structures
i think this is the best structure in
the world for white and
you know you can just never lose if if
you achieve this structure so the king's
indian
just refuted this opening obviously bad
this structure is just too good
but how do you continue here what should
the plan be for
beliavsky in this position
arthur is talking about a larry evans
still make it i did
see that game and i actually opted for
this game over that one i think both of
those games
have been called the snail maid of the
century at some point
but uh this one just a little bit more
impressive to me
i don't think it was against benko
though i don't remember who it was
but not benko
rook c1 b4 and c5 so yeah definitely
white is aiming to expand on the queen
side here uh
the the saying goes you should play on
the side where your pawns point
in this case white has a little bit of a
triangle but black's pawns are clearly
pointing towards the king's side so
we're looking to play towards
the queen side with stuff like b4 and c5
and white actually just doesn't waste
any time at all and plays b4
this is something that is kind of fun to
note
you don't really want to be playing a
move like rook b1 or
rook a to b1 or rook a to c1 in these
positions
and the reason for that is after a move
like
i let let's even say black passes for
example after a move like b4
if you get met with a5 and a3
you would much rather have a rook
sitting on the a file just to help
contest
this open file so that's why we see i
think white plays b4 right away
now rook f to c1 is potentially a
reasonable move but i do like this
immediate b4 by uh beliavsky
we do see a5 by black and now a3 for
white
rook a6 for christensen he's trying to
be very clever
by giving himself the opportunity to
double rooks before opening the a file
but it's coming a bit too slowly here we
see knight b5 now
for beliavsky goes after this pawn on c7
it's a little bit awkward
to hold everything together knight b6 by
christensen
and now we do actually see rook a to c1
seemingly breaking that rule i just told
you about
but notably uh white actually kind of
gains a full tempo here
because he left the rook on a1 black
wasn't interested in
opening the a file until he was certain
he could take
control of it and so we forced black to
play this
rook a6 move when maybe black would have
rather just
open the file immediately we do now see
ab4 ab4
and queen d7 by black but unfortunately
in this case the counter play down the a
file is not going to be enough to make
up for these pawns sort of rolling down
the board
and all the extra space that white has
we see queen d3
for whites rook a4 and now queen b3
uh is just touching this rook we get
rook e to a8 now
and rook f to d1 and again we are sort
of just preparing for an eventual c5
here although for the moment our knight
is a little bit loose
h5 now by black makes some left and
threatens h4 ideas
so white plays h4 himself get g6
now rook b1 will defend this b-pawn in
the meantime
while white gets ready to defend this
knight and push c5
okay we do see knight g4 now by black
and with the pressure on the e4 pawn
eliminated
we just see bishop e2 with again the
idea of a c5 move to open things up
queen e7 fights against this idea by
defending the square
so we see rook b to c1 so you know on
the surface these moves sort of look
like almost
random maneuvering but they're all sort
of with the purpose
white understands that i just need to
gradually build up
towards c5 black isn't really going to
be able to stop me in the long run
there's not enough counter play down the
a file and so
all i need to do is prepare this break
and life should be good
so sensing the danger here black
actually immediately plays the move c6
which is
a pretty big concession here opening up
the
uh d file allows white to target this
weakness on d6
and invade with the major pieces so c6
definitely admitting
that the opening has not gone his way
black managed or white managed to take
over the game
with this threat of c5 of course if
black played some slower move probably
c5 is just coming right away
and i mean this this is just very very
ugly
even something like c6 is playable here
and
you know these weaknesses are are gonna
be uh
pretty lasting here on the uh on the
queen side of the board white is gonna
eventually start challenging this a
file invade with the queen and that's
that's just gonna be game over
not much you can do about that one so
c6 instead we see dc6bc6 um
and now c5 is the interesting idea
combating the threat to the knight with
a threat to the other knight of course
if you were to
take on d6 here you're actually going to
be running into a little bit of trouble
with some knight takes f2 counter play
ideas
as well as rook a3 and rook g3 coming in
so we do see c5 instead by beliavsky
we get dc5 bc5 now knight d7
and yes knight to d6 does come into play
now uh we see knight d to f6
by black and now white to move here and
sort of consolidate the advantage we we
did the hard part
we out maneuvered black and got our c5
breakthrough
now we have the more active pieces and
we should have
sort of a winning tactic here and then
you know barring any swindles
the rest should be smooth sailing
do i have this game memorized no i have
the notation in front of me i put it in
delete chess before i started
a big cheater like that
i guess it's also called you know
preparing for your class
sometimes i do it
manny says knight c8 that
looks like it attacks a queen but um
actually it's a kind of interesting move
i guess black has to go to queen f8
but i don't really see a good follow-up
here
after queen f8 of course you can't take
the knight because the rook on a4
i'm not gonna lie to you knight c8 never
crossed my mind
but um looks like a reasonable move but
doesn't really
you know prove an advantage here in
knight b6
okay so knight b6 there is rook a3 to
deal with right
and then or k7
and maybe you're making some progress
here but there's something a lot more
direct
than uh than that
queen takes f7 check that looks like it
loses a piece
so i'm a little hesitant and kasparov
again has the right answer
you know i don't know what else i should
expect from kasparov in the chat room
but bishop c4 is is the move and
now you know unfortunately that pawn is
really hard to defend
um it's just kind of that simple this
pawn is
really really tough to defend you can't
play something like rook f8 because this
rook hangs
technically knight h6 is a legal chess
move
but playing like that's not gonna get
you very far and something like queen b6
is maybe the simplest to follow up
there's always going to be threats of
taking this guy anyways
and i mean this is just this is quite
sad
quite sad so let's flip the script here
and start playing for swindles okay we
got outplayed all right we're larry mark
christensen now
we got outplayed white just understood
the position so well
uh played b4 got c5 in without any
difficulties
we're just dead lost on the king's side
so let's start swindling
how how do we swindle here chat how do
we start
playing for swindles
bring bishop into play and press f7 yeah
we did it
it was bishop c4 we did it
now stop finding good moves for white we
only want to find the bad moves for
white
we want to find the ways for white to uh
to go wrong
so arthur has the swindlers move with
knight takes f2
so here's something important to realize
about swindling
you're not swindling anybody by playing
knight h6
okay nobody's getting swindled if you
are sort of just
shelling up and you know waiting waiting
for the
you know just taking all the punches you
know there's a time and a place
for sort of turtling up and just taking
the punches and hoping you survive
but you know that's that's not gonna
make it into the class on swindling
so when you're swindling you need
something to play for
right in our previous game schlecker was
sort of playing for this past d-pawn
trying to make his opponent slip
up and uh try and take
an easy path that might be wrong in
order just to get rid of the
you know the one threat remaining the d
pawn in this case
black doesn't really have any threats in
the position
there's not really anything to play for
here for black aside from turtling up
that is unless you're willing to start
sacrificing some material
so in order to swindle we see
christensen here
sacrificing the knight on f2 and
going for play against the white king
let's see how it works out we get king
takes f2 by beliavsky
you can also throw in this check but
bishop takes f7 isn't going anywhere
anyways so we see white hold off on that
for the moment
we get rook a3 and now white does go
ahead and capture here
king g7 and now queen to e6
so how do we continue now with black it
looks like we're in some pretty dire
straits here
uh we just sacrificed our knight and it
appears that our opponent is either
checkmating us or trading the queens
and neither of those seem like very
appealing options if you are the side
um down a full piece so how do we
continue how do we keep the swindlers
the swindles rolling
yeah manny suggested rook a3 and rook a3
is probably um
similar i think you can maybe still take
on f2 later but this one is a little
more direct
what a move yeah queen e6 it's a pretty
good chess move it's a pretty good chess
move
knight g4 night chief what everybody
wants knight g4
knight g4 is actually not going to be
the right idea here um
and i'll explain why in a moment but
does anybody have uh
any other ideas yeah and arthur has one
other idea that in this case
is going to be correct once again the
idea is to go
rook a2 check now why is rook a2 check
a better try than knight g4
well for one it's a swindle disguised as
a swindle
right so the the swindle is that like
okay
you know the swindle is black's playing
hoping for
something like queen a2 rook a2 bishop
a2
and then we go knight g4 and like and
try to check this guy
we have a queen our opponent doesn't
maybe you know something
goes wrong here we have like 93 stuff if
the king goes this way
king g1 maybe there's queen a7 and again
some problems for white right so
that's that's what we're telling our
opponent the swindle is right we're
saying oh okay
i'm trying to swindle you take my rook
ah see
but then the second swindle comes into
play after this king moves back
okay here's the second swindle so what
was the idea of rook a2 what was the
swindle within the swindle
and yes the swindle within the swindle
is to hang our queen
and play rook 8 to a3 and now all of a
sudden things are you know a little bit
dicey for white here it's like wait a
second
i thought your your queen was attacked
but then of course
the idea is that the king is cut off
on the second rank and there's no
escaping these checks
white doesn't control any of these
squares and we can just check white for
the rest of the game
and that would be a draw so this queen
uncapturable
and we are we're starting our swindle
right we're starting our swindle off
strong here
now why is this better than knight g4
well if knight g4 i think king a2
is going to be pretty simple and if you
try to do something similar
now the king and the rook are able to
communicate without that one file gap
and white is just winning so knight g4
king e2 is going to be the problem
so game continues rook 8 to a3
and white it's like okay hold on you
know i'm alexander beliavsky
i'm not about to take your queen here
okay all right i'm not a [ __ ]
so we do see 98 check instead which is
actually a
very powerful move the point here is
that if you play knight takes e8
this is going to be checkmate and 2
which is not ideal
not ideal so black keeps the game going
here
and just plays king to h6 again you know
please take my queen
uh that's fine just take my queen i
don't care
and white is like okay obviously i'm not
going to take your queen
and instead i'm going to take your
knight on f6 highlighting the fact that
after rick takes g3
i have king h1 and boom i do control one
of these squares
and no perpetual check life goes on
uh as usual so
this is the game continuation how do we
keep trying to swindle our opponent here
what can we do
and yeah i like arthur and manny's
suggestion that's what christensen chose
in the game
just take the bishop just start taking
pieces over here with your uncapturable
queen
now of course queen takes f7 uh
disconnects the queen from the h3 square
and
that would be the same draw by perpetual
check
but all is well we see rook d7 now by
white
clearly this was all part of the plan
and this is a
a pretty strong move actually by white
here now of course
it's white's turn to say ha you can't
take my queen
because i will checkmate you on h6
and so uh black has
other ideas in mind here so black to
move in this position
how do we complete our swindle complete
the swindle against belliowski
yeah rook d7 i you know oy savonos in
the chat room
rates rook d7 three scared face emojis
and i tend to agree
maybe even four maybe
so keep in mind guys keep in mind what
our our swindle is here
our swindle has been that we want to be
able to check the king on all of these
squares
and that doesn't really work anymore
right like uh
you know for one this rook is moved and
so now this square is controlled and the
black
white king can run over here so keep
that in mind when you're coming up with
with swindles now
keep that in mind
who will find the master swindle
by larry christensen and remember
the best swindles are always sort of
disguised as other swindles rook h3
the rook is already on a2 i don't
understand that one
arthur doesn't see it people are saying
like one moves but you got to tell me
the idea
gotta tell me the idea if you think you
have it
like you can't just say rook h2 talon
tell me what the idea is
like rook h2 white has one legal move
white's gonna take it
yeah manny says queen f6 there's no
perpetual rook g
to g2 but there's still no perpetual
there
there's still no perpetual white can
still run
away
rook g to g2 i think white can just take
the queen and if you start checking
again i'm gonna run
and hide behind my rook
queen takes rook i mean white just takes
it these aren't swindles these are just
all right i don't think the chat's gonna
find it which is
nice you know this doesn't happen too
often it doesn't happen too often peop
whenever i ask like a tough tactical one
people always come up with it but this
one
this one takes a human eye
all right almond says queen takes f6 and
he says it like five times but he
doesn't tell me the idea
what's the idea rook h3 is no good he
just takes it
he just takes it
and i think manny has arrived at the
idea
queen takes f6 with the idea not of
perpetual check
but of stalemate and that's what happens
in the game
we see queen takes f6 and in a moment of
weakness
believovsky lets his guard slip he says
you [ __ ] i take here i control
f3 rook h3 check doesn't work anymore
and then of course he is absolutely
stunned
by the move rook h2 check and
with this snail mating idea there's
simply no way to continue the game
rick h2 white has one legal move and now
we keep the king pinned to the back row
here and
this rook is uncapturable pawn pin to
the king
king unable to move and the king is
unable
to escape this is also stalemate
and that is going to be the end of the
game with
the stalemate of the century really
impressive swindle here by christensen
it really
shows you the the art of swindling here
he's always disguising his swindles as
other swindles so
when you think you've spotted the trick
there's one more trick
another level deep that is the art of
swindling
uh perfected here by christensen
now there is one more uh swindle i want
to show you guys
from larry christensen here and it's
actually going to be my favorite type of
swindle okay so
there's these nice swindles that are
like you know cute little tricks
that the opponent misses and the next
thing you know you forced yourself
into a stalemate but nobody likes
drawing chess games okay you know it's
you get a little bit of a rush
when you're dead lost and you and you
draw but what's better
than being dead lost and getting a draw
well it's being dead lost
and then winning anyways and this is
probably my favorite example
of one of these kinds of games we have a
player by the name of james
burden with the white pieces who is not
a famous name from chess history
i think he is just some random master
level player
playing in the north american open in
las vegas against of course
american chess legend larry christensen
and so
just some random master level player has
the white pieces against larry
and the game starts off fairly normally
right it starts off fairly normally
larry is doing you know whatever garbage
opening um
castles queen d2 we see d5 now
by larry nothing too crazy right larry
let's white build up a little bit of a
center now he's
challenging it we see some captures go
on
take take take take take now e5 making
his own claim in the center
we get d5 and at this point larry's like
all right what kind of patser am i
playing right now like what kind of
panzer am i playing just queen h4 check
you lost your e4 pawn you you stupid
dummy
stupid dummy so we get queen of two and
larry takes the free e4 pawn
white castles queen side and at this
point i like to imagine that christensen
is just like falling asleep in his chair
or something
you know it's some random round in the
north american open which of course
isn't open it's like just a swiss
tournament he's playing some random you
know low-level master
so larry's just like pl whatever i'll
play a5 i'll go checkmate the guy a3
a4 like i'm up the e4 pawn this game
this game's just over right this game is
just over bishop g4
you know whatever knight e2 knight d7 um
you know like whatever um but then
there was a bit of a shock on the next
turn so
you know larry falling asleep in his
chair whatever happened
to miss white's next move here so
wait to move and get an absolutely
crushing winning advantage
white to move here and wake up larry
we gotta wake larry up
nobody sees it yet my goodness
you can do this one chad you can do this
one i promise
it's much easier than the swindles
no not d takes c6 trust me trust me
you've got something really good here
stop looking at like pawn captures and
stuff
okay you're playing larry christensen if
you want to win the game
you know you need something big you need
something big it's not taxi it's not
h3g4
come on guys come on guys queens in the
trap queens in the trap on e4 nobody saw
that the queen's in the trap how could
you miss
that the queen's in the trap all right
let's count the legal moves
can't go to g2 can't go to f3 can't go
to e3 or d3 or c2
can't go d4 c4 or b4
can't go to d5 can't go to f4
that means it's only safe for treating
square is to
f5 and the square it's on is not
attacked as well what move attacks both
of those squares
of course is knight g3 and the queen's
trapped
queen's just entirely trapped here just
in the center of the board
nothing larry can do so you know larry
being
larry is larry whatever so i'll take the
bishop and win the game anyways
so queen e3 queen e3 bishop d1
rook d1 and we've got um we've got a
rook for the queen
so not not too bad but unfortunately you
know james burden might be like a weak
master but he's still a master right he
knows how to move the chess pieces
so larry tries to keep things closed
here with c5
rather than just let white flood into
the position and take over
we see knight e4 b6
now rook f1 larry just trying to hold
things together for the moment
f6 now again just tries to keep the
white pieces sort of at bay
queen h3 now we need to play f5 to keep
that diagonal closed
get knight g5 making a threat knight f6
this move is check so we get king h8 now
knight f7 check is unfortunate
and larry has to start giving back some
more material here so we see rook f7
bishop f7 and now it is actually
a a knight for the queen not ideal but
but things are going to get worse before
they get better
trust me here things are going to get
worse so we see knight g4 by larry
and you know having swindled a few times
myself in my own chess career
in this position you're thinking all
right i might be down a queen
but you're like i control the center
right like look at all these squares i
control
pro i've got chances i've got chances
but
things are gonna get worse okay we get
king b1
larry plays knight h6 just like
attacking this bishop for no reason
and then knight back to g4 like like
what are you gonna do here you know you
kind of have to wait
let white try and do something and then
try and find a trick along the way
we get queen d3 rook d8 now targets this
pawn
d7 e4 and you know what
you know what larry lacks in queens he
makes up for in activity in central
control for the moment
queen d6 and it looks as if like there's
just no way
uh no way we're surviving this one right
like the the queen is invading
white's queening doesn't look great we
see bishop b5 by larry though
queen e7 bishop back to f6 this move is
check so we start running up the board
king h6 h3 and now unfortunately this
this bishop must die as well so we see
knight at e3
now queen takes f6 hits the rook on d8
so we get rip takes d7 and at this point
larry's down a queen for two pawns okay
that's that's just the material count
no getting around that one um and many
of you guys at home are gonna start to
see
many many wins along the way which fair
enough
you know of course larry should have
lost this game being done a queen for
two pawns
but you know what james does it's sort
of understandable right he's just trying
to like play his game
he's probably excited you know he's
beating larry christensen doesn't happen
every day
um and rather than play a move like rook
f4 which is just immediately checkmating
black
um you played queen e6 instead just like
attacking the rook defending the bishop
like whatever you know he's thinking i'm
up a queen for two pawns
rook d4 though attacks this guy we see
some more tactics here with rookie one
now of course if knight c4 that would be
met by
something like pawn to c3 and some
complications
so larry instead does the only natural
thing and starts taking more pawns right
you know
we're not winning the game by like
trading off pieces here like knight c4
running into c3 and stuff and like our
knight's gonna get pinned
um we're winning the game by promoting
our pawns right we got to make a new
queen we lost our first one so knight g2
we see rook g1 by james now knight f4
queen g8 and e3 again
the key to any good swindle is number
one having something to play for
in this case we're not going to check
mate white with a rook and a knight so
what larry is playing for here
is these extra pawns that he has he's
trying to make them relevant
he's trying to get them down the board
in order to beat
his opponent here that being said james
has checkmate on his mind and plays
queen f8 check
after king h5 see the move h4 which is
sort of a weird idea
to try and checkmate i guess on the g5
square
of course this maybe shouldn't be
captured on account
of checkmate and three
um so we see rook c4 instead and this is
perhaps
you know the big practical mistake that
uh
james here uh sort of makes he's like
all right i'm just gonna checkmate him
i've had enough of this game
but in the process gives up the bishop
now now it's a night for the queen
okay knight for the queen not bad
um we see queen back to f6 now and james
probably thinks like you know this idea
is just unstoppable
uh the king comes back to h6 and now
unfortunately
we see james mess up once again so it's
actually just mate
like immediately with rook to g5 here
um queen f8 is very very difficult to
stop uh you can play something like 96 i
guess
number one this could be captured number
two this move is actually checkmate
and the game would be over instead
though james plays queen g5 which is
sort of very very strange
the king just steps to g7 now we see
another check
the king steps back and if you're larry
christensen not much reason to not
repeat here
queen takes e3 the e pawn is dead and it
looks like her swindling chances are
dying as well
but larry just keeps playing you know
you just keep playing like why not just
keep playing here
so rookie four in the game we get queen
f2
now knight h3 big time fork big time
fork look out
queen d2 is check king is a fighting
piece one of the only ones we've got
left so king h5
rookie won now and
larry finally says okay i'll take it
i'll take i'll take the rook and we have
sort of the last stage of the game now
so larry up to this point has been
fighting admirably
down the full queen but at this point
there's no other pieces left on the
board
it's literally just a queen for a knight
and a couple pawns
like shirley surely white is going to be
able to convert this
but we'll see that you know larry just
keeps the threats coming just plays
f4 and it's like yeah you know i'm just
going to play f3 f2 f1 and you you can't
stop me dude my knight's just too
strong um and apparently you know james
just kind of falls forward he plays
queen e7
which is just a very weird move if i'm
white here
i'm just bringing the king into the game
and making sure that this pawn never
promotes
but instead we get queen e7 and you know
james is playing for trackmate or
something
h6 guards the g5 square to free up the
night a little bit
we see queen to f6 now and g5 and
the pawns are just rolling now the pawns
are just rolling of course
white's still completely winning but um
all of a sudden
these pawns are going to be a little bit
scary and then white does something very
very strange which is queen takes b6
now i don't know how nonchalant you can
be here against larry christensen
after not checkmating him for the past
30 moves being up a full queen
but queen takes b6 is a little bit
ambitious it's a little bit ambitious
because now
f3 is coming right now f3 is coming the
queen on f6 stopped f3
i would have even played something like
queen f5 here to stop
f3 and stop king g4 but instead we're
getting queen takes b6
and now larry's just pushing queen c5
takes off another pawn
but these pawns are coming these pawns
are coming
and now we see queen e3 by
white and believe it or not after queen
e3
um the evaluation is is uh
sort of a draw here like um there's no
this is the point of no return for white
out of nowhere larry christensen is
suddenly drawing this game with the
knight versus the queen
uh turns out the way to do it was with
f2 larry plays king g3 instead
and now the game keeps going for a bit
we get c4 king g2
c5 f2 and then queen e4
check and once again the evaluation goes
back down
to a draw seemingly out of nowhere
probably what white was hoping for was
something
like king to g1 when there are a number
of ways to win with white but maybe the
simplest
is to just stop this pawn from queening
and then queening a second pawn getting
a second queen
and having one less pawn to worry about
from the black side
instead though larry finds this really
tough move
king h2 and now the problem
is that we're not necessarily queening
our f pawn
but we're queening our g pawn as well so
now
after the similar idea of queen f3 same
idea as queen c4 just to stop
f1 we are suddenly pushing g4 with tempo
and that's a problem for white that's a
problem white has to go queen e2 now
now after g3 things are very very very
very scary
um so now we're looking at white to move
and draw
because larry is going to be winning
after the next turn
uh believe it or not the only move that
comfortably draws here for white
is king to a2 just stepping off of the
back rank
and the point now is that after the
natural continuation of g2
we're going to play queen e5 check queen
g3
and we're going to be able to take this
guy with
some perpetuals so for example queen f1
we get check
and this king is not going to be able to
escape our clutches um
but obviously you know still it's still
not easy for white
still not easy instead white plays the
natural move of c6
but after g2 it's just entirely busted
now
for white after something like c7
this would actually be a fork and black
is going to be up the queen
that's why we see um queen e5 check but
this also doesn't help
we just make both of our queens and now
unfortunately
c8 queen loses to a number of things
including
i guess the simple way is just to go
queen c1 and take the newly made queen
um white played king to c3 and larry
found
the checkmate immediately with two
queens it's not super hard
so why is this one of my favorite
swindles it looks like
you know white was winning the entire
time until he made a mistake
in the the end game there by letting the
pawn get too far
but um this is just the all-time classic
swindle i love
playing games like this with black
where you're just down like an
insurmountable amount of material
but you just keep playing you know you
just keep playing you keep making moves
and then all of a sudden you're in some
end game still down a queen by the way
but like you've got a past pawn and then
all of a sudden your past pawn is two
past pawns
then your two past pawns are two queens
and then white's in checkmate
just i love to see this kind of swindle
from larry christensen
um and that's why that's my favorite
swindle of the night
uh let me know which swindle you guys
like the best in the comments
down below as always i want to thank you
all very much for watching we've got
sabina foyer
coming on the channel next looking at
some pretty interesting positions from a
book that she wrote
she wrote a book can you believe it
wrote a book
with uh i believe her fiance or maybe
husband now i don't know
el shawn morata body and it's super
interesting stuff i recommend taking a
look at that lecture
but that's it for me here tonight so as
always my name is caleb denby
thank you for watching and i will see
you guys next time
you